Okay, Eric says, I just asked this question in the group, but looking for input as well,
what do you tell a potential BO to say to the customer that just called our Legion site,
then called the BO's website and got the same person for both companies?
I have an easy answer. What do you say, Kyle? Somebody calls the Legion site,
then they're shopping for the second one, they get the same person on the phone.
I just tell them that's a marketing site we have. She's like, oh yeah, we have a handful
of marketing sites that all generate leads that funnel back to us.
Here, I'll give you mine. Kyle, pretend that you're that person.
Yeah, pretend you call me out on it.
Yes. Yeah, this is Joe, Joe's Concrete.
Yeah, I just talked to you from another site.
Okay, yeah, that must be a sign. I mean, obviously, no, I would literally say something
smartass like that. Like, yeah, no, obviously, we're the best company in town. That's why we're
everywhere. But that's just one of our marketing sites. We have a couple of different sites.
Just depends on what you search. How can I help? You ready to get that estimate done?
Let's get this scheduled.
Tuesday still work for you, bro.
You want me to bring the frickin concrete when I come or you want me to wait? Okay.
It's not a big deal. So to answer your question, Eric, this goes for any objection.
That's not even an objection. If it's not a big deal to you, it's not a big deal to them.